[Music]
very unfortunate when you inadvertently
find people agreeing with you who the
hospital who wish to agree with you I
mean I despise Trump
I despise everything that he that he
stands for but it's perfectly true that
many people think that I ought to be on
his side because he had these draconian
illiberal horrible policies towards
Muslims in kind of stop Muslims entering
the country what a horrible thing to do
what are water and an impolite unwise
illiberal inhumane thing to do and so I
am I'm embarrassed if people on the
outright agree was set with something
that I say for the wrong reasons
there's not a great deal about religion
in science in the sole most of what I
have to say about that is in my earlier
book The God Delusion so I can rehearse
that if you wish to me as a scientist
the main argument is a scientific one I
think that the hypothesis that the
universe was created by a supernatural
intelligence is a scientific hypothesis
it's a bad hypothesis the false
hypothesis but it has to be judged on
its scientific merit the universe would
be a very different kind of universe if
there was a supernatural creative
intelligence in it then if there wasn't
so much of my argument is a scientific
argument there is no positive reason to
believe in anything supernatural if you
look at all the reasons that have been
offered none of them stand up none of
them hold water we have in the form of
Darwinian evolution we have a superb
theory of why living things have come
into being why they are the way they are
why they look as though they've been
designed and they undoubtedly do look as
though they've been designed the
illusion of design and living things is
immensely powerful and it's no wonder
that until Darwin came along almost
everybody believed that it was created
by a supernatural
religions but we now have Darwin we now
have Darwin and his successors we now
know how life came about and the
complexity and the beauty the elegance
and the illusion of design of life has
always been by far the most powerful
argument for the existence of
supernatural gods and that is completely
blown out of the water
the secondary argument is whether
religion has evil effects where the
religion has bad effect and on balance I
think it does the real problem is that
religious faith prize itself or not
needing support you can't argue somebody
out of their faith they simply say oh
that's my faith you have to accept it
and that means that if their faith tells
them if their religious upbringing tells
them that they must do bad things like
blow things up kill apostates throw gay
people of high buildings etc if their
religion tells them that then you can't
argue them out of it because it comes
from their faith and faith by definition
has no argument faith by definition and
shelter behind the wall that says no
it's my faith I don't have to defend it
it's just there it's just faith that I
think is potentially very evil that's
very far from saying that every
religious person is evil of course many
people do good things because of their
faith that's great but the fact that
faith can lead to and does lead to
significant numbers of evil things and
the horrific repression of women for
example in certain theocracy and of gay
people in theocracies be the sentences
of apostates to death be the joyless
suppression of music and art and fun in
certain countries because of religious
indoctrination religious faith the fact
that this can follow from religious
faith the people who do these awful
things don't think they're terrible they
think they're doing good they think
they're being righteous they think
they're obeying the will of their
God and that they're going to go to
paradise because of it that I think the
closet has the potential to be evil we
have to regard that as an evil
[Music]